well there were films on it and all
sorts of press and magazine covers it
was the car of the moment what we have
behind here is a 1966 Ferrari 365 P tre
posti and tre posti is italian for three
seater so it's really a wonderful story
it's the marriage of three great minds
Enzo Ferrari Luigi Chinetti and Sergio
Pininfarina and really they all got
together and said let's create the
greatest supercar of the 1960s and
Pininfarina said if I can get a race
chassis from you Enzo Ferrari I can
build the greatest supercar but what I
want to do is create a Ferrari where the
race car driver or the road car driver
sits in the middle with two passengers
on either side at the heart of every
Ferrari is the engine and this car has a
12 cylinder four and a half litre engine
basically a racing engine and this
gorgeous one-off Pininfarina coachwork
this part was really immortalized in a
great cartoon there's this fellow
Brockbank
British cartoonist Enys he has an
Italian obviously driving the car in the
middle and on the side of the road our
wife and a mistress fighting over each
other as if they're fighting over the
man who's driving in the middle of the
car so it's always been known as the the
mistress automobile
if you look at a car like this Ferrari
and just you know step back I mean this
was a car that was produced as a
functional object but really it's a hard
for me